in only his second day in office the new
Brazilian president came to pay his
respects to the man who'd given so much
to his country Lula offering words of
comfort to pele's third wife Marcia and
his six children
when he was at his moments of Glory when
he met the Queen of England when he won
an award Pele was the same guy as when
he was giving an interview or met a
group of children
pele's casket was loaded onto a fire
truck draped in the Brazilian flag and
started its journey through the streets
of Santos
the procession moves slowly along the
beachfront towards his mother's house
a poignant moment as his 100 year old
mother Celeste has outlived Brazil's
most famous son
Pele was able to carry the Brazil name
around the world Pele was the first
Global brand today Pele is only third to
the pope and Jesus exactly what I was
speaking with my wife she said but
you're going to see a a truck a a fire
truck with the with the food with a
funeral I said it is the same that the
the UK people did to the to the Queen
the only man to win the World Cup three
times Pele reinvented Brazil as the
country synonymous with the beautiful
game and lifting its image around the
world he walked around without a no
safety guard nothing you just walk
around that City in a car driving or
with a pilot and no no safety no
security you know and he loved it here
right he loved you yeah of course of
course he loved Brazil
the celebration of his life and
everything he came to represent
continued as the motorcade double back
to give the fans who'd come out in their
thousands the chance to see him twice
[Applause]
[Music]
pele's last fixture was a private family
funeral at the world's tallest vertical
Cemetery he picked the ninth floor as a
tribute to his footballer father donino
who wore the number nine shirt we
visited the cemetery just 24 hours
before he arrived in the city
this is the exact spot of pele's final
resting place he bought this plot around
20 years ago and at the time he said I'm
not scared of dying and another thing it
isn't Pele who's been buried in the
memorial he is Immortal he is eternal
it's Edison he's been buried
he'll always have a view of the Santos
Stadium Edison Arantes de nasamento was
interred next to his father but here in
Santos in Brazil and Beyond his Spirit
lives on it will always be Viva valet